pues ya hemos pasado el Ecuador de esta
jornada electoral en España y hasta el
momento absoluta normalidad en todos los
colegios electorales Incluso en melilla
donde anticorrupción está investigando
una posible trama de compra de votos por
correo los primeros datos de
participación hasta las 2 de la tarde
muestran Un aumento de un punto y medio
por encima de las últimas elecciones de
2019 es decir un 36,6% de los más de 35
millones de lectores que podían
participar en las municipales lo han
hecho ya los resultados de participación
de las autonomías o regionales los da
cada autonomía pero en todas ha
aumentado la participación los colegios
electorales abrieron a las 9 de la
mañana y estarán abiertos también hasta
las 8 de la tarde los primeros
resultados preliminares o provisionales
los conoceremos a partir de las 10:30 de
la noche Marina hablemos ahora de cuáles
son las claves de estas elecciones
teniendo en cuenta como decíamos
previamente las elecciones generales
previstas para fin de año
exacto y es que es muy importante
recordar esto de que hoy lo que se vota
son las elecciones municipales de todos
los municipios más de 8.000 y las
regionales en 12 de las 17 comunidades
autónomas en las que se divide el país y
es que España tiene un sistema parecido
al de Estados Unidos y por eso estos
gobiernos que se eligen hoy son
cruciales porque son los que van a
determinar las políticas de por ejemplo
viviendas sanidad medio ambiente o
educación y los resultados de esas
elecciones van a afectar mucho más
directamente a la vida de los ciudadanos
que unas elecciones generales que como
bien decías se aproximan serán a finales
de este año y por eso todo el mundo está
pendiente de Hacia dónde va la tendencia
del voto de las 12 comunidades autónomas
que se juegan su gobernanza hoy 10 están
en manos de la izquierda y dos en manos
del derechista partido popular sin
embargo las encuestas muestran
el declive de la izquierda en todo el
país y un posible auge del partido
Popular en varias regiones Eso sí quizás
dependiendo de los votos o de
coaliciones con el partido de
ultraderecha vox es el caso por ejemplo
de Madrid cuya sede de gobierno está
aquí a mis espaldas en la Puerta del Sol
Isabel Díaz Ayuso Parece que va a rozar
la mayoría absoluta ella es del partido
Popular de derecha Pero quizás se quede
corta uno o dos escaños Así que tendrá
que hacer una coalición con vox y ella
ya ha dicho que ha dejado la puerta
abierta una de las regiones clave para
la izquierda será la comunidad
valenciana ahora gobernada por la
izquierda pero que podría caer en manos
de la derecha en estos comicios